[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
when you hear call of duty how do you
react is it positive maybe a little
negative whatever your response you have
to admit the modern warfare series was a
masterpiece
well that series is having a partial
reboot this year next month in fact but
let's not talk about that let's talk
about what we can do right now because
at this moment you can download and play
the 2v2 alpha completely free and it's
only on the ps4 but it gets better than
that
you don't need PS plus to get your hands
on this this is open to the entire
PlayStation 4 family simply download and
get into the tactical two-on-two battles
the goal is to win five rounds before
the opposition does but there is a
spanner in the works load outs are
randomized you may be handed a scoped
shotgun or a rocket launcher or maybe
just a simple pistol randomizing
weaponry forces us to change our play
style to keep the game feeling fresh
there are 5 maps to master two of which
have never been seen before so you could
be the first to play them other changes
include or rather exclude in the
mini-map it's gone your hearing is
needed to get the drop in fights and
cooperation and coordination remain the
key to coming out of this alive and if
the game becomes too tense and a bit of
a stalemate an over tank flag will
appear the first team to secure it wins
the round the event only runs for 48
hours hence the title of the video only
one weekend starting on August the 23rd
and ending on the 25th so why the hell
are you still watching this video go get
it downloaded even if you've walked away
from the series I recommend having a go
and see if this Call of Duty is the one
for you no mechs no space suits its back
with our boots firmly on the ground if
you're watching this video as I release
it you can pre love the game right now
to maximize your gaming session of the
weekend as soon as the server's go live
you'll be in there jump over into the
PlayStation Store under banner will
likely hit you in the face but if it's
not there just simply search for modern
warfare and you'll get it I don't think
this video needs to be any longer does
it I will see you on the battlefield let
me know what you think about revisiting
the modern warfare series I'm
from Playstation grenade it's been a
pleasure see you soon
[Music]